in this capsule we will see the concept
of dynamic Bezier network then in
the capsules on the networks need
dynamic we will obviously see the
defining a dynamic Bezier network
we will focus on two types of
dynamic Bezier networks to know chen
of markov is a model of kosher markov
we discuss different types
of inference that can be done in a
dynamic Bezier network can we
interesting to reason
probabilistic in a dynamic context
and we're going to look at
different inference procedures in
chest
the particular case of mac os models
hide then we saw the Bézian networks
now here what we want
to be interested in doing is to try to
mobilize dynamic situations
that is to say situations finally the
notion of time passing and the notion
we collect observations as
and as time goes by
so in this case also our model
our beziers network is going to be dynamic
as far as our random variable
will be indicated by the time or
associate these different variables
then the dynamic changes that
will enough to infer or model one will
see it as a state sequence we're going
see the random variables x you are
so we see here that each variable
random x is going to have a clue it's
so a screen up aix grant is a
great and that would be the end of a period
that we try to model and so x that
will match the non variables
observables it's the notation that we're going
use we will sometimes say the
hidden variables
it's the variables that will describe
the state of my environment that
I do not observe directly but that I
would be interested a ferrer and will have some
random variables
m when we see clues and loses the
try and that's going to be novara bhl who
are going to be piqm in observe ie
to do better than time will pass
we will know the values ​​of separating at
block we will be able to conditioned on these
variables to try to infer the
variables that do not
interested in knowing the variables that
are in the observe so that's for in
set we use the word evidence for
talk about this type of observation there
again these variables are
indicated by the tempt so the theme
dynamic here in the Bézian networks that
reflects the fact that we will actually have
we will mobilize an environment where we
know that the distribution of what we
can observe from the state of
the environment changes as and when
as time passes and so the
dynamism comes from the fact that we have a
system that is dynamic whose
distribution of the state evolve as
as time passes and also
we can recognize it by the structure
of the network that will be distributed in
time to say that as we will
see rather or a bezier network that goes
to extend unfair time what a complexion
future then let's see some examples
of applications with the little guns
competent and approached with
dynamic first Bezier networks that
is really classic it's the one of the
speech recognition in that
if our observations nonverbal at what
i sava correspond squarely to the signal
sound so the measures there signal
sound that actually comes from the person
who speaks and what is observed and who
wants to transfer the variables
hidden maybe it's actually the words
or the sentence that pronounced the father speaks
to no one
so in fact in systems of
classical voice recognition which
will be served if the signal and the state
hidden actually going to be distributed 1
different concepts have from the
signal we often go incidentally
of abstraction little bit more so a
a little more abstract representation
based on what are called phonemes
that we can understand as being
basically consonants and
syllables pronounce from that we're going
want a ferrer the words that have who
match his fans love water
that were pronounced for then
build a very intelligible sentence
which is presumably what the
pair
we tried to say so that all of this
together often match to excite
and what is observed is actually going to be
the signal the machine translation or
if it's an application we can
tried to model with networks
bezina but in this case imagine it
we want to do a translation of the
French to English well what is
observed it's going to be the words of the sentence
in French that we try to translate and
then what is hidden that we try
to interest the words of the sentence in
English
so we have an example here that has been
generated by google translate the
paragraph here tiger is actually a
body description and 215 at university
from sherbrooke and you have here
actually the generated translation so in
this case we see a way to approach
this problem no is to define a
dynamic Beziers network where the
observations hide it's going to be the words
in English since it will be observed
on têt the words in french
third application is tracking
of objects that is to say we have one
video
and then we wish identified in a
video of which he initiated a single frame
so every frame or clothes in
English of the video be identified or
his 6th of the objects where are the objects
when if the objects we are interested in
it's the players in a game is
so what will be observed is going to be
the pixels in each trams so
you are in fiv at 1,10 and each of the trams
video
and then excited it'll be
essentially random variable
contains all the information about the
position of each of the objects
in the frame so it will contain
information on finally this
rectangle there that is around
different people in teeth
in the part you have a link here that
you will be able to visit the power a
demonstration of a tracking system
of objects and finally the localization
robots so
imagine that we have a rebound that is
represented here by the little circle and
who is in a building but who
do not know where he actually is so
all he has to determine his
position it's the censors of lasers
who can launch the in all
directions to try to measure
what is the distance between the robot and
the different walls of the room in
all possible directions around
of him and so this information there that
would be what would be observed by the
robot and information hide the
knew to infer that would be the
robot position in the map
so we will assume that the robot access to
a map of the building to which he is
find he's just not where and from
of these censors as lasers there
let it wander as the
time flies by a ferry or is it
who is troubled in the map
so that's another example
application that we can try to
solve with Bezier networks
dynamic